-Welcome to the Fake News
Awards. -The Fake News Awards.
JACKSON: We're headed
to The Washington Post
to talk to some journalists--
AKA liars, losers, and haters--
about what it's like
to be nominated.
And since it's an awards show,
we're bringing the red carpet
to them.
JACKSON: The glitz,
the glamour, the lies.
We couldn't believe
we were there on the floor
of the world-famous,
Jeff Bezos Washington Post.
SHARP: Seriously,
why did they let us in here?
We spoke to Margaret
A. Sullivan, media columnist
for The Washington Post,
about this historic night.
First-time nominee, because
it is the first time the awards
-have existed.
-Yes. Are you so excited?
Well, you know, I think the Fake
News Awards are a very bad idea.
So you're saying it's an honor
just to be nominated.
No, in fact, it's not only not
an honor to be nominated
but these awards
are actually, um, a disgrace.
And the president
has really turned that phrase,
"fake news," into a weapon
against the free press.
And I disagree.
Well, you know, you're entitled
to say whatever you want.
Exactly.
But that doesn't mean that
the public should believe it.
Okay, and who are you wearing?
-No comment. Interesting.
-No comment.
SHARP: Also excited for
the awards, first-time nominee,
media critic Erik Wemple.
What's the deal
with this, uh, carpet remnant?
-It's an awards show.
So we're... -Right. -Yeah.
I think, myself and most
of my... most of my colleagues,
um, we got in the business,
uh, with the intention
of never receiving an award of
any sort from anybody we cover,
so I don't know...
I don't know why...
I don't know why you have
this carpet remnant here.
We came to sort of celebrate
the big deal,
the big awards show, you know,
big deal President Trump
nominating fake news,
uh, mainstream media,
sort of taking it down in sort
of a funny, presidential way.
What do you think about that?
Sir, sir, sir, sir.
Would you care to comment
on the Fake News Awards?
Okay.
(sighs)
Don't you think the Fake News
Awards are pretty funny?
You know, I really don't like to
use the expression "fake news,"
because I think
it's been weaponized.
We need to stay close
to what is provable
and verifiable reality
and not get into the idea
of separate sets of facts
-that might please a particular
audience. -(music playing)
-We need to sort of...
-S-Sorry to interrupt.
They're telling me
you need to speed it up.
-Yeah, they will play you off
if you take too long. -Yeah.
Okay, well, "fake news"
shouldn't be used anymore.
Don't you think news is true
if you believe it?
I think news is true
when you prove it.
-Interesting. Interesting
opinion. -Yeah, what an...
No, that's not an opinion.
Oh.
That's not an opinion.
Is there gonna be
a big after-party?
I don't really know
of any parties.
-I'm certainly not planning
to attend any. -See?
People keep saying that to us,
-and it's as if either no one
respects these... -Right.
...because they're a detrimental
force on our world,
or there's just
a secret party...
-Yeah.
-...that you don't want us at.
No. It's actually
that they are a detrimental
force on our world.
Okay, but do you know
where I can get cocaine?
I do not.
-Fake News Awards red carpet.
-Good luck to everyone.
Good luck!
JACKSON:
So there's
-no after-party.
-Uh-uh.
I guess nobody cares.
Nobody cares about real news.
-Yeah, as in the kind
that we agree with. -Right.
-Do you have cocaine, though?
-Yeah, I have a D.C. guy.
Oh, thank God.